[Musique]
salut tout le monde alors dans cette
vidéo on va regarder une partie qui
s'est jouée lors du dernier title
tuesday sur trois points comme et qui a
opposé maxime vachier lagrave avec les
pièces blanches à aboul haggag dit mme
ben ali avec les pièces noires alors
maxime vachier lagrave j'imagine que
tout le monde le connaît je ne vais pas
le re re re re présenter abdullah kadi
mme ben ali c'est un jeune joueur azéri
âgé de 18 ans il est classé 2470 salafis
délain être international c'est un
excellent blitzer il a eu un classement
maximum en blitz à 2982 sur check point
com et joueur très talentueux
il a notamment été champion du monde en
moins de huit ans alors pour
recontextualiser cette partie c'est la
dernière ronde du title tuesday qui se
joue en cadence 3 + 1 dans cet itunes
dès le top 8 va dans la phase finale du
tournoi et pour se qualifier les deux
hommes ont absolument besoin de
l'emporter donc là nul n'arrange
absolument personne ici l'analyse on va
faire comme toujours sur thiès comme et
d'autant plus quand c'est en en blitz en
format blitz en rapide allez on y va
maxime qui jouent ces cas dont qui
jouent pas sont eux quatre plus habituel
mais ça peut se comprendre via les
candidats qui reprendront un jour ou
l'autre et à essayer du bit sur internet
donc ces quatre les noirs qui joue ses
six donc l'idée c'est comme ça sur des
quatre il veut jouer des cinq est
transposée dans une slave maxime qui
joue cavalier f3 cavalli est 6e 3 donc
il temporise il attend pour jouer des
quatre ils le retardent ce coût de prise
du centre de toute façon les noirs ne
peuvent pas jouer cinq la case et
contrôler les noirs qui jouent des 5 et
maxime qui joue b3 donc qui prépare le
flanquer taux du fou en b2 ici les noirs
peuvent jouer des systèmes en sortant le
foin f5 ou angers 4 mais ici il a joué
g6 et il va partir pour un double filles
en quête au four b2 vers dans l'oeuf une
enquête au fouet cette foule de petit
rock petit rock coûts de développement
logique et b6 pour aller mettre le fou
en bessette et dans un deuxième temps
peut-être joué avec ses 5 pour s'ouvrir
petit à petit la diagonale de ce fou
maxime qui prend finalement le centre
par des quatre les
art qui joue faux bessette cavaliers c3
développement et e6 donc on voit qu'on
est dans un genre de système colle avec
les blancs c'est à dire qu'on a fait le
d4 c43 b3 en ami le fou en b2 donc qu'il
restait derrière la chaîne de pions et
dans cette structure généralement l'idée
des blancs c'est de jouer eux quatre
pour prendre le centre et après des
échanges peut-être jouer des cinq pour
s'ouvrir la diagonale du fou b2 les
noirs vont soit en position plus solide
un ils consolident leur centre avec ses
6 6 et ils sont tapis dans l'ombre à
attendre le 4 ils échangeront en 4 ou c4
et ils joueront ces cinq pour avoir les
deux fous qui crachent sur les
diagonales donc un jeu de préparation où
il va y avoir un feu d'artifice quand ça
ouvre au centre dans cette position à
namur avait joué c'est prendre et 5
contre caruana y avait eu c d e des
caruana et finalement gagner avec les
noirs mais la police la partie était
compliqué maxime lui qui joue à quatre
avec l'idée d'envoyer à 5 à 6 heures
pour illustrer le danger admettons
cavaliers b 17 à 5 et dams et 7 qui
serait pas très bien joué par les noirs
ici on pourrait jouer à six attaques et
de fufu c8 et on voit que les noirs ont
déjà moins d'espacé parce que leurs
pions sait si ceux ci sont moins avancé
que ces 4 et 2 3 qui va partir en 4 et
maintenant plus la case bessette
n'existe plus pour le fou donc ça après
des dames ces deux on sent que les
pièces noires n'ont pas assez d espace
donc sur à 4 le joueur azéri qui va
immédiatement réagir et il va jouer à
cinq qui empêche à 5 pour les blancs et
donne la case b4 aux cavaliers
le cavalier maxim qui vient de f3 en
cinq dons qui se place bien au centre
les noirs ici qui ont joué cavalier 17e
pas oblige on aurait pu faire cavalier à
6 mais pourquoi pas et maxime qui
renforce son cavalier par f4 comme ça
sur cavaliers prend il pour apprendre de
2 2d ou de f mais peut-être plutôt de f
plus naturel à première vue même si
parfois des ses bons et on voit quoi il
a bien en mur et le fouet pour avoir
l'idée de jouer le 4 avec un gros centre
qui restera derrière donc après f4 les
noirs qui ne prennent pas le cavalier et
qui joue maintenant cavalier à 6 alors
dernier petite chose parce que ça pour
arriver à n'importe quel coût dans la
partie si on joue avec hafsi
pour chasser le cavalier blanc les
blancs vont revenir en f3 et ils
joueront par la suite un petit coup 2e 4
avec l'idée de jouer contre ce pion
arriérés lorsque la colonne s'ouvre
puisqu'ils a plus le pion en f 7
c'est pour ça que les noirs ne chasse
pas le cavalier non plus par f6 il joue
cavalier à 6 dan des deux maxime qui
développent ces pièces cavaliers bk donc
le cavalier qui atterrit sur cette belle
case tour a des seins centralise la tour
dames 7 développe la dame et e4 donc
pour prendre le centre finalement c'est
un peu le seul plan des blancs pour
avancer donc s'il est noir pourrait
prendre quatre mois c'est souvent ce qui
me paraît le plus logique genre qui
avions pris un cap qui prend le quatre
tours à des huit avec l'idée de jouer
pour ces cinq par la suite et d'avoir
les deux diagonales bien ouverte et
mettre la pression donc sur ces cinq des
quatre sur la case des quatre sur la
diagonale noir et à avoir la diagonale
blanche ouverte
c'était jouable dans la partie il a pris
en c4 il laisse toutes les reprises sont
possibles ici pour maxime
mais reprendre du cavalier avec l'idée
de jouer e5 donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
peut-être intéressant de supprimer ce
point 4 qui fermera la diagonale du fou
et qui donnera accès à la case des six
jours par exemple sur ces cinq ici un
coup comme le 5 est possible mais on en
reparlera dans la partie avec cette case
des six qui va être joli
pour le cavalier les noirs sur qui prend
ses quatre ont joué tour à des huit dont
kim et la tour en face de la dame les
blancs qui jouent aux 5 et donc ce c5
dont je vous parlais pour ouvrir la
diagonale du fou maxime ici qui joue
cavalier des six donc ils profitent de
cette belle kazan des 6 et gagne un
tempo sur le fou son adversaire répond
par s'éprend d4 et attaque le cavalier
c3 alors maxime joue très vite un pour
mettre la pression sur son adversaire à
la pendule il a pris dans les quarante
secondes une minute d'avancé
et ici va rater une petite opportunité
il aurait pu prendre intermédiaire avant
de reprendre en d4 sur bessette qui
attaqueraient la tour après pions france
et 3 il aurait pu donc pour récupérer la
pièce jouée fou prend ses 3 il n'y a pas
de découverte puisque si lecavalier
bouge on prend des 8
donc on est obligé de bouger la tour et
le cavalier qui revient en dés
6 et ça stratégiquement c'est très cool
puisque les noirs ont perdu leur superbe
fou sur la grande diagonale blanche le
fou g7 du coup il est fermé donc la
fermeture de 5 à napa n'a plus le
l'inconvénient d'avoir ouvert le feu
deux cases blanches et et les blancs ici
sont mûrs ils ont un avantage d'espacé
ils ont une bonne position
maxime a raté cette petite opportunité
il a joué cavalier cb 5 mais qui paraît
très intéressant aussi parce qu'il
maintient la pression sur le fou
bessette et il attaque le pion des
quatre qui va pouvoir reprendre du
cavalier mais après fou des cinq
cavaliers prend des 4 et cavaliers c5
les pièces noir réussissent un petit peu
à contourner ce cavalier des 6 et on
voit qu'il a le petit duo de pièces
mineur ce qui attaquent le pion b3 le
cavalier b4 bien placé et ce cavalier
des six qui après un coup comme f6 pour
être vulnérable donc la position est
loin d'être claire adam 3 a joué par
maxime protège le pion b3 tour des sept
fous b5 attaque la tour alors ici tout
reprendre et s'ils se prend des systèmes
prend des six est toujours une option
mais il n'y en a pas forcément très
envie de jouer avec une qualité de moins
même si si ça doit être correcte les
pièces mineurs sont très actives on a
quand même un pion pour la qualité mais
beaucoup plus logique de rejouer tour
des des 8 x 3 pour maxime
il se met sur une diagonale où il ya
beaucoup de trafic de pièces noires
plutôt intéressant et f6 bien joué de la
part de son adversaire qui veut miner le
pion aux 5 pour s'en prendre aux
cavaliers des six on ne peut pas jouer
puis on prend même si c'est juste pour
illustrer à cause de dame prend f6 enfin
c'est pas très intéressant le cavalier
se retrouve mal et et les noires
s'activent de partout visuellement on
voit que ça ne va pas donc ce puits il
faut vraiment le garder en jeu 5 maxime
qui joue fou prend b4y se débarrasse de
ce cavalier qui était pénible apprend
des 4 et cavaliers c4 rebondi protège un
peu le pion aux cinq monts qui l'est
déjà mais il vient leur protégé et sans
lever le problème du cavalier des six
mais aussi il vise le pion à b6 son
adversaire qui joue dame bessette est
ici leur dire aux commandes qui avaient
des six mais on imagine que la dame
repart en deux sets et il se passe pas
grand chose
maxime qui vous tous rêvent 2 et ici son
adversaire on manque de temps rate une
petite opportunité d'échangé en 5
l'idée c'est qu'on peut pas reprendre du
cavalier ce que maxime aurait envie de
faire à cause de fou
prend b3 qui joue sur le clouage
maintenant que la tour ne défend plus en
d1
et si on prend du plomb après pour
preuve deux on si on prend la dame va
peut-être perdre le pion aux 5
et si on prend du roi mais on sent que
c'est plutôt les pièces noires qui
commence à être mieux placé il ya plus
d'activités pour les noirs avec des
belles synergies
deux partout et donc ça prenait
l'avantagé pour les noirs et un petit
coup comme dams et 7 pour renforcer la
pression sur cinq avec avec les clous à
jandun aurait été pénible mais dans la
partie surtout rev 2 il joue le logique
cavalli eu 4 qui s'en prend à la tour
maxime qui part avec la tour en ces deux
cavaliers c3 il se place sur une
meilleure case et il attaque la tour d
un tour 1re protège le pion aux 5 et
sort du cloud h désagréable sur la
colonne des qui on prend aux cinq
cavaliers prendre 5 maintenant possible
pour ces 8
ici ils se placent food et cette attaque
la tour et s'en prend aux pions maxime
qui a réfléchi assez longuement pour
jouer ce fou 17 et ça va rentrer dans
une variante forcer son adversaire eu un
peu de réussite et parce que je suis pas
sûr qu'ils aient tous vu au moment de
jouer des tours c'est 8 il a joué assez
rapidement et ça va rentrer dans une
autre tactique force et donc leur menace
la tour et le pion donc il va prendre 5
intermédiaire attaque le fou fou prend
ses huit force et attaque la dame fou
prend des 4 on n'a pas attendre fou
prend bessette parce que fou prend 3 c
sur échec et on récupérera en b 7 à la
fin donc on n'a pas vraiment le temps
même si sa finale peut jouer mal être
plutôt avantage noir
donc on n'a pas pas vraiment le temps de
faire ça donc maxime qui prend et prend
pas en b 7 mai prend en d4
les noirs qui prennent ans et 8 maxime
qui reprend maintenant en b4 attaque le
cavalier lecavalier qui part en quatre
c'est une grande vraiment quasi-forcée
un tour prend ses huit dames france et 8
et d'autres coûts possibles on va dire
que tu as vraiment envie de rentrer là
dedans jusqu'au bout sur la variante
qu'on avait énoncé lorsque lorsque je
regardais en live et ici le problème
pour maxime c'est que s'ils jouent tout
reprend 2,4 dont qui serait la
continuation peut-être logique à
première vue il ya dame ces deux menaces
la tour 4 et on peut pas la bouger parce
qu'il ya dame pranger 2 on est obligé de
jouer dams est fou prendre 4 et
perpétuelle mais comme je vous ai dit le
problème c'est qu'on peut pas faire nul
et là on peut pas faire le bluff côté
blanc parce que si on fait tout
reprendre 4 qu'il est obligé de faire
dame ces deux et on sera obligé de faire
dams est donc si on joue ça en fait si
maxime joue tout reprend au 4 qui est le
meilleur coup d'après leur dis ça fait
nul automatiquement et les deux joueurs
sont forcés de rentrer dans la variante
pour pas être perdant donc collègue
rachidi perdant c'est complètement
perdant donc tout reprend 1,4 pas
jouable donc d'altran b6 et il va jouer
il va jouer pour les pions passé face
face aux pièces mineurs et à l'attack de
maths son adversaire qui joue dame c2i
rentrent ils attaquent g2a 5 on envoie
le pion alors on peut pas prendre en b3
pascal cavalier e 4 qui restera en l'air
mais il fait cavalier ces trois menaces
échec et mat en g2 donc maxime qui est
obligé de revenir avec dame f2 une
nouvelle fois on peut faire dame des
huit dames 7 et les perpétuelles mais
son adversaire c'est que maxime ne peut
pas faire le perpétuel donc maxime qui
joue dame f2 dame prend b3 sur dame
preuve de roy prend le pion à va être
beaucoup trop fort en plus sur vous
prend surtout prendre les trois on va
juste envoyé a6 et a7 et ça c'est très
cool pour maxime les pièces mineurs
défendent très mal contre un pion passé
éloignés comme cela donc après damev de
son adversaire qui joue dame prend b3 et
a6 est comme je disais maxime qui
apparaît qu'il ya pas vraiment de bol
parce que chaque fois qu'il ya des idées
de perpète
bah c'est lui qui doit les refuser ce
que c'est lui qui sera à l'initiative de
la nul donc il peut pas jouer ses
variantes là bon il envoie le pion en a
six ici son adversaire alors dix
cavaliers de d1 qui déplacer la dame et
qui permettait d'être mieux après d'amd
de dame b 6e 3 h un cavalier de roy
jackets detroit et à petit à petit les
noirs réussissait à désorganiser la
défense blanche
mais honnêtement c'était extrêmement dur
à trouver en bits lecavalier des
impasses que c'est pas un gain rapide
qu'il a joué le truc logique il a joué
qu'un valide des 5es l'idée c'est que
maintenant sur a7 il va faire damas
trois et il va pouvoir s'emparer du pion
à qui est bien bloquée donc maxime après
kébé 5 qui comprend que son pion à est
condamné il par attac et de l'autre côté
par h
4 damas trois dames b6 donc à l'hôtel et
deux joueurs sont mal autant se montrer
au monde cette partie là ça envoie à
toute blinde mais à maxime qui a
toujours une quinzaine vingtaine de
secondes de retard et son adversaire
commence à se rapprocher de la zone des
3 4 5 secondes nous on ne remonte plus
il joue damas deux maximale 1 le marlou
fait dam des huit échecs 3g cette dame
cet échec
roy g8 dame g5 maintenant les petits
échecs il se remet angers 5 et il va
préparer h5 dame prend assise prend le
pion h5 donc ces manants maximin kiala
l'initiative de l'attak puisque il a
réussi à envoyer les pièces noires
allèles dames notamment le cavalier une
pièce coûte pour porter qui a du mal à
courir et la dame g5 qui attaquent le
roi noir et défend le roi blanc
puisqu'il défend la casse j'ai deux sens
inverse actifs d'amd six échecs roi h2
d'un f2 donc revient à attaquer se
mettre sous pression le pion et la tour
tour c'est un maxime se place sur la
colonne ouverte pour rentrer avec la
tour cavaliers des six empêche tour c8
et donc ici maxime qui a le choix entre
alger et h6 et il a choisi alger alors
le truc sur h 6 il a peut-être pas vu
mais les noirs peuvent bien défendre
après qu'avait lieu 8 oui là il a dû le
sentir tour ses 8,3 et vii tour des huit
pouces et 6 bon j'ai juste mis sa vente
rapide pour vous montrer que les noirs
réussissent à tenir toutes les cases sur
la septième rangée et du coup le roi
noir se fait jamais mettre en échec sur
la septième et il est très difficile à
déloger
du coup un set-up genre de forteresse
noire et et la dame qui peut pas
vraiment partir aider la tour parce que
y'a le pion g2 sous pression donc maxime
qui a eu le bon réflexe après qu'il ait
décidé de jouer hg il ouvre le roi parce
que si ça peut être tentant mais c'est
le bon réflexe ici son adversaire qui
aurait dû jouer à 6 avec les noirs parce
qu'il ya pas d'un prend 1,6 à cause de
dames pranger de maths et sajoo loin
d'alger 4 et sajoo mais il a joué à
alger et a maintenant après dame frangé
6-3 et fuite dame g5
on sent que ça commence à être plus
difficile à jouer pour les noirs parce
que la dame blanche protège le pion à
g2 et les blancs veulent jouer d'atours
c'est cette dame cette dame g7 mat
donc c'est pénible ici à noter que
d'après le redis avait une manière de
sauver pour les non enfin plusieurs
manières mais la même idée de sauver
c'était dam des quatre avec l'idée sur
tours c'est cette d'attaqué pour
attaquer de jouer damache huit échecs il
ya paroisse g3 cause de cavaliers e4
fourchette et suroît g1 dam des quatre
il ya un échec perpétuelle mais comme je
vous le disais on l'a déjà les joueurs
n'ont plus de temps et joue avec avec 2
3 secondes sur la pendule
mais psychologiquement de toute façon
quand tu sais que tu peux pas faire nul
tu vas même pas penser à des coups comme
d'am dam des quatre dames h 8 même si
très difficile même voire impossible
avec si peu de temps à trouver mais de
toute façon c'est pas dans son
algorithme allées noires qui ont joué
cavalier f5 ici tour ses huit échecs
wife cette tour ses sept rois f8 et
d'amd huit matchs donc avait laissé
inquiéter l'erreur fatale
je suis passé rapidement mais voilà ça
fait un petit matin de l'escalier avec
tours c'est une tour c'est 7 6 le roi à
ne repartez pas en rêve 7 mai en huit y
avait d'alger matt de l'autre côté
donc j'espère qu'alex acker fatale qui a
mené à le match en 3 j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à lâcher
un petit boulot si c'est le cas et on se
retrouve très bientôt au qatar
[Musique]